20 днів між першим і другим туром президентських виборів -
шанс для кожного з кандидатів
переконати виборців голосувати саме за нього.
Петро Порошенко робить ставку на традиційно
"свої" теми, як армія чи російська агресія.
Володимир Зеленський тим часом знову ламає стереотипи.
Він не з'являється на люди, а висловлюється
у записаних відеозверненнях. При цьому
звернення "по суті" можна перелічити на пальцях однієї руки.
Його найсильніші козирі - це найслабші місця чинного президента:
інвестиційний клімат і боротьба з корупцією.
Одна з головних тем Петра Порошенка
у передвиборній кампанії перед другим туром -
це технічне оснащення армії. Адже міцна армія,
на думку президента, - дорога до миру,
тож кандидат за лічені дні після першого туру
встиг відзвітувати про успішні випробування
контрбатарейного радару, ракети "Нептун" та комплексу "Вільха М".
Володимир Зеленський не позиціонував себе
як кандидат, що відстоює інтереси військових.
Утім, в інтерв'ю, що вийшло в запису на телеканалі "Україна",
заявив: його пріоритет - зупинити стрілянину
на Сході України. Як Володимир Зеленський
збирається це зробити, кандидат не уточнив.
Примітно, що військові в зоні проведення
Операції об'єднаних сил у першому турі віддали
більшість голосів за Володимира Зеленського.
На цій темі намагаються зібрати голоси
обидва кандидати. Петро Порошенко позиціонує себе
як компетентний та - головне - сильний політик, який
здатний говорити на рівних із Володимиром Путіним.
Проблема лише в тому, що багато українців, які
хочуть такого діалогу, не вірять у те, що Путін
говоритиме з Порошенком. Це один з аргументів
прихильників Володимира Зеленського, які хочуть
покласти край війні і вірять у те, що з Кремлем
можна домовитись. Володимир Зеленський
у свою чергу заявив, що готовий до перемовин із Володимиром Путіним.
Обидва кандидати вважають, що до миру треба йти шляхом діалогу
у межах "мінських домовленостей". І обидва кажуть,
що їх треба не лише реанімувати, але й реформувати.
Зеленський не уточнив, як саме.
Порошенко натомість 12 квітня має зустріч у Берліні
з канцлеркою ФРН Анґелою Меркель, на якій
збирається вкотре обговорити виконання "мінських угод".
Реформи й корупція - слабкі місця Петра Порошенка
попри те, що низку реформ йому вдалося втілити.
По цьому слабкому місцю намагається вдарити Володимир Зеленський.
Він хоче запустити антикорупційний суд і почати
саджати за ґрати злочинних високопосадовців,
чого за 5 років не вдалося Петру Порошенку.
Чинного президента виборці звинувачують
передусім у тому, що він, сам олігарх, не зміг
відділити бізнес від влади. Утім, чи вдасться
"деолігархізувати" країну кандидату, якого відверто
підтримує інший олігарх - Ігор Коломойський?
Для виборців актора Володимир Зеленський - це
передусім нове обличчя, яким Петро Порошенко
був у 2014-му році. І вони готові дати йому шанс
попри відверті симпатії до нього Коломойського.
Петро Порошенко одразу після другого туру -
з 21 квітня - обіцяє важливий етап повернення
українського суверенітету на окуповані Донбас і Крим.
При цьому незрозуміло, які нові обставини
дозволять це зробити саме після другого туру виборів,
якщо досі зробити цього не вдалося.
Володимир Зеленський натомість хоче відновити
зв'язки з людьми, що живуть на окупованих територіях.
Риторика президента швидше войовнича:
він обіцяє повернути українських
військовополонених із Росії та з підвалів на Донбасі.
Володимир Зеленський хоче достукатися
до жителів Сходу України, переконати їх в тому, що
російська пропаганда запудрила їм мозок, а Україна
їх любить і чекає на повернення у свій склад.
У питанні євроінтеграції Петру Порошенку
є чим похвалитися. Це безвізовий режим із ЄС
та угода про асоціацію, які він реалізував
за свій перший президентський термін.
Утім, підтримка вступу до НАТО в Україні нестабільна,
передусім у східних областях. Тут ініціативу
перехопив Зеленський, який обіцяє достукатися
до серця кожного східного українця і пояснити, що
НАТО - це не алігатор, який проковтне Україну, а безпека держави.
Попри напружену конкуренцію двох кандидатів
напередодні другого туру, традиційною
політичною агітацією займається поки що лише чинний президент.
Він ходить на ток-шоу, підтримує родини політв'язнів,
презентує нове озброєння і переконує українців,
чому йому конче необхідні їхні голоси.
Шоумен здебільшого продовжує займатися
своєю основною діяльністю - розважати українців.
У даному випадку - на передвиборні теми, такі як
місце проведення дебатів та аналізи.
Його звернення - змайстровані кліпи, подяки
за підтримку чи ось такі спортивні побажання
без жодних передвиборних гасел.